there's no evidence in my files there's
nothing wrong everybody knows I'm
innocent Andrew Tate and his brother
Tristan have hey guys
so on today on today's video I'm going
to be
serious videos that have just dropped of
Andrew and Tristan Tate going from
police custody to the courthouse I'm
gonna give you my honest opinion and my
honest analysis of what I can see
happening here and just before we get
into this video If you appreciate this
kind of content then please don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe as
I'm going to be keeping you up to date
and I'm following this very closely okay
so the first video I have is from on
demand news I've never heard of them the
title is the Matrix is trying to frame
me handcuff Andrew Tate lashes out
Andrew Tate and his brother Tristan have
claimed there is no evidence against
them as they remain detained in Romania
the controversial social media
personality so I've just seen Andrew go
from police custody to the van I see no
lashing out immediately the news
headlines are biased he's saying that
there's no evidence and that the Matrix
are trying to frame him no lashing out
it immediately implies violence like
he's lashing out against some kind of
journalist or he's trying to get away
from the police he's just talking
defending himself very peacefully I'm
going to go back a sec I also noticed
Andrew looks rough he looks tired
obviously he looks like he's been in
prison I've never seen Andrew look like
that before it's very interesting to see
him like that in contrast to how we
usually see him always looking very
sharp on point groomed so yeah he he
looks like he's been in prison
handcuffed together outside Romania's
anti-organized crime agency as they
faced more questioning the story you
should be covering is
is there an interesting place there is
none that should be the story on the
news prosecutors carried out forensic
searches of seized items from the
brothers on Wednesday as they looked for
further evidence in the case that's a
really good point that Tristan Tate is
making he's saying that there's no
evidence whatsoever so how the Romanian
authorities able to extend the time that
they have in jail by another 30 days
surely that's the human rights violation
surely that's what the media should be
asking how are you putting these two men
Behind Bars without a fair trial without
evidence also I'm gonna go back you'll
notice the use of all these weapons so
by showing money guns swords and all
these weapons they're just trying to
make it look like they are guilty as if
these weapons were the weapons that were
used when they supposedly did all those
things that they're being accused of
it's just so crazy when there's just no
evidence like this isn't evidence which
proves that they are guilty of what
they're being accused of the next video
is from The Daily Mail the Daily Mail
are okay um they don't seem to be
particularly left or right-wing but I
definitely think they are very
sensationalized Andrew Tate and brother
Tristan asked the police what evidence
they have is this the end of your career
Andrew
I know we've done nothing wrong
there's no justice did you hurt any
Garden so firstly again he's denying the
charges the woman just asked him did you
hurt any girls Andrew said of course not
but then he said that there's no justice
in Romania he's saying that Romania is
corrupt which is so fascinating to me
because that's actually one of the main
reasons why he moved to Romania because
he felt that it was the least corrupt of
all the other countries including the
United Kingdom America so the fact that
Romania is now sort of like turning on
him is really interesting does this
potentially mean that the Matrix is
everywhere and it doesn't matter how
many grids you're on or the systems in
those different countries they're all
basically one and they're all out to get
you I don't know I wonder why he didn't
just stay in Dubai because it seemed
like Dubai was okay
[Music]
do not get rich in Romania
again there's no evidence and it's so
bizarre to me that they're able to keep
these guys in custody with no evidence
while they build a case I've never seen
anything like this before usually when
there's no evidence they go free
everybody complains but it's true
there's a lot of media pressure there's
also International pressure and then I
don't know if you noticed but Tristan
said they're going after him because
he's Rich Young and Powerful I believe
that at this point if there's no
evidence against somebody how are you
keeping them in jail well because you
clearly see them as a threat you see
their power their influence their money
as a massive threat
carefully
people hate him so much or hate them
both of them so much that they would
rather people were actually hurt than
God forbid they were innocent so the
next video is from the telegraph so the
telegraph are actually okay and they
don't seem to be left or right-wing so
this is as you take claims vile is empty
as he's taken for further questioning in
Romania so again this seems pretty
neutral in comparison to the first one
that is why I'm in jail I have money
that they were trying to steal
nothing wrong they know we've done
nothing wrong
there's no justice in Romania
unfortunately did you hurt any girl
again Tristan's saying they want him for
his money
um The Matrix were out to get him the
system's out to get him Audrey's saying
the same thing the case File is empty I
agree because if there's just no
evidence how are you keeping these two
guys behind bars it's so bizarre to me
Andrew and Tristan Tate so influential
that I believe the UK government are
spending billions of pounds to
re-educate young kids in school that is
how much of a problem the Tates are to
the system so I agree with Tristan and
again Andrew's saying how Romania is
corrupt that's just such a shock to me I
think it's quite sad as well when you
invest in a country because you think
that you'd be safe there and then they
turn on you like this the next video
that we have so this is just from a
random account I don't know who they are
Andrew Tate grabbed by fans leaving the
police station
there's no evidence in my file because
I've done nothing wrong everybody knows
I'm innocent it's okay everyone knows
also I've done a few caught but he said
that God knows I'm innocent obviously we
all know that Andrew converted to Islam
last summer so it's really good to see
that all of this trouble hasn't shaken
his faith and God still feels you know
aligned with God and I think there's
another video I saw or a picture I saw
of him walking out with the Quran it's
good to see that he feels that there's
hope safety and love in God despite all
this craziness going on right now I also
noticed the guy that Taps him on the
shoulder and then tells him to stay
strong the way Andrew responds is really
calm really collected I think that's a
really good sign that he feels very
confident that he knows he's innocent
people know he's innocent and most
importantly God knows he's innocent so
as I've said many times I find the whole
thing very very bizarre I still don't
understand how you can keep people
behind bars when there's just no
evidence how do you keep somebody in
jail while you're building a case so I'm
going to be keeping my eye on what is
going on here I'm doing a Twitter spaces
next week so definitely jump in there
and give us your opinion let us know
what you think about all of this I think
everything seems really really
suspicious but like I said I'm going to
be following the story so definitely hit
the like button and subscribe so you
never miss a video